i've flown back to england and flown
back to japan in the time yeah uh since
the last not even the last record and
then you got to go like a week later
again so why'd you leave a scan
why did i leave um basically i had to do
a marriage interview now normally people
do it like a year or something before
their wedding but unfortunately due to
uh
yeah due to like travel restrictions
i didn't have the opportunity
to uh go back to england to basically do
this marriage interview which is like
legally wait so fill me in what do you
have to do at a marriage
like yeah you haven't got the job yeah
yeah
yeah okay i'll get so why do you want to
get married
i'll get into why like we like i i had
to do it but yeah legally like if i
wanted to be married in the uk
you need to give something called a
notice of marriage which is basically
you're telling the government that
you're like planning to get married um
and so it
brings you to the legal proceedings to
allow you to get married now right so
normally you can do that like a year or
months before unfortunately due to
travel restrictions and like us not
being able to travel back to the uk or
just it being incredibly difficult uh we
kind of like put that off and we put
that off and we put that off and we put
that off and then
you you have to legally give it at least
28 days before you get married and by
the time we gave it it was like
35 days before we got married so
are you still still on the guidelines
yes it's it's still in the guidelines
but it was kind of awkward because i had
to leave the boys for just like two
weeks or something like this kid who
finishes the assignment the day before
got plenty of time i got a couple of
hours left yeah so i was like looking at
the schedule and i'm just like
[ __ ] we got like trash taste and all
this other work stuff that we need to be
doing and i gotta give my notice of
marriage otherwise i can't legally
legally get married yeah i've put this
ass i've put this off for as long as
possible but it's just it just makes it
a bit awkward because otherwise i would
have traveled back to the uk a little
bit later yeah um because now i'm back
just for literally like about eight days
just to do like my filming commitments
and film all the trash chase episodes we
need to film yeah um so yeah i don't
even know if i'm going to like tweet out
that i'm back in japan because like it's
honestly not worth it because by the
time i tweeted out i'm gonna be tweeting
out okay i'm back in the uk now
um and so another thing is that this is
probably like the most timely trash
taste episode you'll ever be able to see
uh because we are filming this like what
like three days three days three days
before uh it actually airs or something
like that yeah so
um it's like the one time there where we
can talk about current topics and it's
the one time where it's just like there
isn't really any current topics yeah
before we started we were like all right
guys it's finally time we can talk about
some timely things and we just sat here
for five minutes trying to think of a
timely subject yeah we couldn't think of
anything
we should just pick something like
really irrelevant yeah
that's crazy
oh my god yeah but yeah basically this
notices marriages it was mostly just
like
you know about lawful procedures
um just making sure that uh we can we
can be lawfully married uh so like
normally they just ask you like normal
questions like oh i was being asked you
know what is spell spell your fiancee's
name you know what's what is her name
hopefully i know her name right
really that's like that's a like gotcha
yeah yeah yeah no he's like spell her
name and then uh
ask uh you know what is her birthday no
uh i don't actually know what would have
happened if i failed by the way yeah
like like what if i didn't know about it
my last name is a pretty tricky one to
spell but it makes no sense so
i got it wrong oh
i think they want to check that it's not
like a sham marriage of course yeah like
like you're not just doing it for the
visa yeah yeah yeah exactly but uh yeah
hopefully you can spell your partner's
name know their birthday if you don't
now that you know what's going to be
asked you need to know where you're
getting married this will be on the tip
and it is a test because like they
separate you right they're like okay
this is we're just going to be asking
some simple questions whatever yeah and
like even though i know like it was
simple questions just like being
separated it was kind of like it kind of
felt like being in like an interrogation
like why are you here why are you
getting married
like is she you real is she a real wife
she could be your real wife
it was nothing bad like they were just
like you know just details about basic
details you hopefully should know about
your future wife and everything like
that um and then we get to the end of
the interview and then they [ __ ]
throw you a curveball right so here's me
asking where are you
here's here's me here's me asking uh
being asked to spell sydney's name what
is sydney's name what is sydney's
birthday where are we getting married
when are we getting married yeah one of
my parents names etc etc and then out of
nowhere they are they just ask you
are you in any way related to sydney and
ponywars and i'm just like what do you
mean related as in like brother sister
cousin anything like that
hopefully i'm about to me
i just like [ __ ] the [ __ ] orimon
music starts playing in my mind i'm like
yo is this guy is this person a gigantic
fan and like it was like
it was it was so out of left field that
i literally just like
and then like i like let out a laugh i'm
like
and i looked them in the eye and they
just like looked me like dead ass back
just like no this is this is a serious
question this is a serious question i'm
like
no i am not related i'm not brother or
sister i'm not her cousin or anything
like that and
uh what if they were just like does this
song ring any bells and just plays clara
it's like
does this give you any weird feelings
yeah i'm like they actually said
afterwards like you'd be surprised how
many people say yes really i'm like well
i didn't realize i was getting married
in the state of alabama here like
yeah apparently it's like it's it's
surprising how many like first cousins
try to get married like like i guess
there's a lot of
groups that
have a tendency to marry within family
yeah like do you fail the test if you
say yes to that or do they just like
they're like okay i don't know
it's the incest test okay what happens
if you fail the incest test i don't know
mary if it's a certain closeness right
yeah yeah yeah you can't in the i first
cousins i believe in the uk you
definitely can't marry if you're brother
or sister i'm not sure
about first cousins i don't know
i don't know
how many degrees of separation
like how many degrees of separation
doesn't have to be yeah i don't know
i'm asking for a friend he's like google
when you google this just when you
google this too much google's like for
real
oh yeah
it's perfectly legal for first countries
to marry in the uk is it is it ashley
okay okay so if you say yes to that
question then they'll be like we'll
allow it we're just gonna silently
because because they didn't they didn't
just ask you know legally by blood they
were like we include step siblings as
well i'm just like god it's domestic
girlfriend all over again
please don't get money please don't get
honey
i'm like i've been training my entire
life for this moment how did they know
what my favorite tags were
stands up knocks the coffee over it
i'm just nervous i swear i'm just
nervous
what are they only one like you're 23
and me to like
because we did we were like legally like
we had to legally prepare like most of
the documents
no so we had to prepare documents which
is all like the standard documents you
would think you would need to prepare
for
like a marriage interview like you know
just you know um your passports your uh
uh your since we're flying in you know
your
tickets are flying in your proof of
address or or like the standard legal
documents so everything else could be
easily proved via our documents i don't
know where how you prove like whether
you're like incest or not like what if
you say yes like well what what
documents
nice yeah
i was just asking
like is there like a [ __ ] incest
tinder or something anyway
yeah i believe
[Laughter]
have you joined any of these facebook
groups
oh my god